j'utilise de la clau en général c'est
les intérieurs je suis sensible à tout
cet univers cependant ici avec cette
nouvelle loi elle est très intéressante
certes comme toute loi elle peut être
modifié amélioré avec le temps et
les infrastructures qui vont aller avec
vont également se développer en termes
d'accessibilité à internet
d'accessibilité à l'énergie
d'accessibilité également à l'éducation
[Musique]
les suivants
le crypto monnaie a un potentiel énorme
pour la sous région
déjà la sous région si vous voyez le
système bot qui est transitionnelle
c'est qu'il n'y a pas une inclusion
financière en quelque sorte pour
emprunter ou fait ou faire la
spéculation faut passer toujours parlé
les banques traditionnelles là ça
facilite pas
j'ai validé sur la coupe du monde on
vous avait déjà parlé de suicide
je ne connais pas c'est pour la première
papouiller
je te connais pas
que vous avez un coeur net non je n'ai
pas internet